when she's inaugurated on wednesday
kamala harris will make history as the
first woman to become vice president
but she won't be the first person of
color to hold that office
that distinction belongs to the vice
president who was sworn in 92 years ago
with a hearty support of the people of
this country
charles curtis a native american served
as vice president to herbert hoover
during his single term in office from
1929
to 1933. i'm just curious why we don't
know the name
charles curtis one reason is
he was a vice president and if you
think about it for a minute lisa
sandemiere is an historian
at the topeka cemetery where curtis is
buried
i mean can you really name very many
vice presidents
curtis whose mother descended from three
different tribes belonged to the cau
nation of oklahoma and
kansas as a boy curtis lived in caw
territory and with the side of his
family who descended from
white europeans but during his rise from
congressman
to senator to vice president curtis
never needed to hide his heritage did
they know he was a native american
sure we needed all hands for everything
and whether they were
male female native
african-american we needed everybody we
had
despite being second in command curtis
wielded little influence
in the hoover administration even
inspiring a character in a gershwin
musical
an ineffectual vp whose only task
is to take attendance at a senate
meeting the senator who's from
nebraska president check the senator
who's from alaska
check the senators from other states
will have to buy their time
[Music]
for i simply can't be bothered when the
names don't rhyme
but before he was vice president curtis
was senate majority leader
and known for being a shrewd politician
and deal maker why was he selected to be
vice president
because they were afraid he'd get the
top of the ticket
he was the senate majority leader and i
got to tell you charles curtis
has some juice but his best known
legislative achievement
the curtis act is seen by many native
peoples
as a betrayal kent blanson is a
professor of indigenous studies and
history at the university of kansas
what it was was to strip native lands
treaty lands
from native nations and to bring us as
native peoples into
the capitalist economic system and part
of this too was a greater design of
assimilation and acculturation
the curtis act ended up stripping rights
from native americans
including curtis's own car nation it was
a way to protect his people
as how he saw it or how he envisioned it
now we have the benefit of hindsight um
you know in the present to be able to
say
that's a horrible decision and even
later on he would regret the decision
while curtis left behind a complicated
legacy
he never tried to distance himself from
his indigenous
roots he faced many uphill battles in
some ways he wouldn't be allowed in
certain restaurants in oklahoma but he
would eventually be a senator and vice
president
listen to what else he accomplished he
proposed
the very first version of the era after
being
one of the first supporters of the 19th
amendment he
uh was a sharpener or sort of shaper
of the gold standard act he he was known
as being you know the consummate
politician because he kept index cards
exactly on every single one of the
constituents that he met
so he really brought home a lot to the
people he's a
fascinating piece of history it really
is undertold
story obviously